jean gabin recevoir la légion d'honneur
c'est quelque chose qui fait plaisir à
tout le monde à lui même bien sûr mais
aussi à tous ces amis qui sont ils
membres jean gabin la légion d'honneur
on sait ce que c'est c'est une grande
distinction honorifique que vous avez
mérité par toute une vie au service de
votre arme
ce que l'on sait moins et ceux dont je
voudrais parler maintenant c'est qui est
jean gabin alors par conséquent si vous
le voulez bien vos nom prénom âge et
qualité que bunge anga par alexis
moncorgé votre âge 55 ans passés je vais
sur ma 56e année et qualité comédien
mais excellente
jean gabin vous êtes mariés je suis
marié père de famille père de famille
j'ai deux filles et un garçon trois
enfants trois enfants 30% de réduction
famille nombreuse et misera notamment et
dans la paix et dans le temps exact
encore parce que vous avez débuté
j'ai débuté en 1922 il vers 22-23 aux
folies bergère car je viens du music
hall j'ai débuté au music hall ensuite
j'ai fait mon tour de chant j'ai joué
l'opérette et jusqu'au jour où je suis
rentré au cinéma c'est à dire entre
anthuriums affrontant quel a été votre
premier film mon premier film était une
opérette
car comme j'étais un jeune premier
d'opérette à l'époque que je chantais je
dansais mon premier film était un film
simple chacun sa chance chacun sachant
chacun se chacun sa chance et durera 10
c'est alors que commence la série de vos
succès c'est-à-dire maria chapdelaine la
bandeira gueule d'amour
la grande illusion entre autres il
faudrait les citer tous puis c'est la
guerre que vous faites dans les forces
navales françaises libres
le quartier maître jean moncorgé puis
que vous revenez en france que se
passe-t-il alors
j'ai eu une éclipse j'ai eu une éclipse
je vais vous dire pourquoi je crois le
savoir maintenant parce que j'étais
parti tout de même en pleine forme si
j'ose dire je suis parti à la guerre
j'avais donc prendre 5 36 ans oui et à
ce moment là je jouais encore les jeunes
premiers je suis revenu avec les cheveux
blancs et ça m'a donné
ça m'a donné les complexes d'avoir les
cheveux blancs parce que je ne pouvais
plus pensé jouer les emplois que je
jouais avant la guerre alors je me suis
cherché un peu j'ai j'ai fait quelques
films qui n'ont pas été très heureux et
puis vous savez le public est parfois
exigeant il voulait probablement me
retrouver comme il m'avait quittée mais
jallet qu'ils en mieux j'avais 10 ans
mieux et ses 10 ans et je les avais
physiquement en plus est sur mon visage
alors
j'ai tourné j'ai eu quelques films qui
n'ont pas été très heureux et puis j'ai
tourné un film avec clément qui
s'appelait au delà des grilles qui a été
un succès et puis j'ai eu la grande
chance parce que c'est une énorme part
de change y trônent dans ce métier j'ai
eu l'énorme chance de tourner touchez
pas au grisbi et touchez pas au grisbi
c'était en quelque sorte une réplique de
ce qu'avait été pépé le moko l'entente
avec si vous voulez 15 ou 20 ans le plus
le film a marché et c'est reparti mais
je vous dis là dedans il ya une grande
partie de chance oui mais il ya aussi
énormément de votre talent jean gabin et
je crois que s'il fallait jouer en
parlant de vous couper icône mais un
beau rôle ça aide beaucoup un acteur
quel est votre violon dingue
on dit que vous aimez beaucoup la
télévision c'est exact je vois je vois
tous les soirs la télévision quand je
suis chez moi j'ai une grande joie elle
met mais ça va tu être ma petite table
avec avec ma femme on regarde on dîne en
regardant la télévision je vous vois
tous les soirs d'ailleurs rouge et le
site
je voudrais maintenant à venir à votre
légion d'honneur je voudrait la faire
voir aux téléspectateurs voulez-vous me
tenir mon épouse merci voici la croix de
la légion d'honneur de jean gabin et je
ne la connaissais pas vous ne
connaissiez pas du tout cas jamais vu
donc je connais mes jeunes pour moi je
veux dire si j'ai déjà vu les gens
d'honneur mais pour moi non parce qu'en
principe le n'est pas encore
officiellement j'ai pas reçu le diplôme
si j'ose dire bien sûr
qui est ce qui va vouloir m je pense je
pense monsieur le directeur de la
cinématographie
je pourrais cormerais j'aurais ben la
légion d'honneur
c'est même une étape dans la vie d'un
homme cela prouve que vous avez beaucoup
travaillé que vous avez beaucoup réussi
et en principe elle marque aussi le
début d'une nouvelle étape dans la vie
vous voudriez bien sûr essayer de faire
mieux
on veut toujours faire mieux la
prochaine fois free mais je voudrais
vous demander tout simplement de rester
au cours des années qui vont venir vous
même de rester jean gabin c'est à dire
leader à juste titre le public français
jours mais rire l'homme que chacun va
voir avec al avance de sentiments du
plaisir va avoir un regard non merci
non ce n'est pas à vous de dire merci
lepage en cavale
que représente ta carrière
je prends la liberté de le faire
ensemble
eh bien merci quand même et merci pour
le public